with zero okay let's place this guy i
think he's um
he's quite a strong player i think i
played him
he's probably russian he's a premier
member and he's uh
slightly below 2800
d4 h6 okay this is collated quickly
g5 okay let's play the one claw just you
know
do something stupid in return
okay now we play a game i don't think uh
yeah i don't think he favored a lot from
this
also maybe he did i don't know
okay let's just take let's try to you
know
wow queen d6 so was it a primo for
or a misclick or uh something else i
don't know
how should i play this maybe knight h3
yeah let's say queen b3 just you know
so after playing king 2 sometimes you
have to play like a chicken
so i'm fine with the coin trade
i actually did not quite get why
everybody is so uh
like emotional about this a double bone
cloud draw between magnus and hicaro
like some people criticize them some
people praise them but in general i mean
come on it's just you know
one game out of many and people just
and decided to kind of joke a little i
mean maybe it was not
funny or maybe it was but in general
it's not a big deal anyway
that's the way i
think about it okay now at least i
managed to trade queens
so i will not lose this quickly probably
but i still have a fair chance of losing
this slowly
okay so i want to bring the king to the
corner finally
that's why i go rookie one and uh
can you fun but maybe i just start by
playing knight c4
yeah now i want to play s3 as simple as
that
so there was no king of one because of
um bishop district
obviously so he goes here
okay i can just go king of fun right
and he plays e5 okay at very least i can
just trade everything
i think it would be slightly better for
white
but not that much i could also take on
d5
and place this version so what is better
yeah maybe there is no big difference
actually i'm just waiting time okay
let's say we take
this way
so he will probably take on g2 anyway
okay he takes on history whatever there
is no
real difference
i pre-moved d-takes obviously yeah but
then i would say he takes
and we go rgd1 i don't think it's uh
completely equal
like it's very close to a draw but it's
a little bit uncomfortable for black
his bishop is stupid his pawn structure
is not ideal
rgd7 is coming as well so he has to be a
little bit precise here
like maybe rookie seven first
okay he plays this way that's a bit
strange
okay
yeah okay so let's um let's take the
line first
he plays
yeah maybe what he plays is kind of
reasonable
[Music]
but it's still i mean still a little bit
a little bit better for white
okay so now we probably take go king g4
and rookie one yeah but then we go k5
and bring the king there
now we can play h4 for instance
yeah he takes which is a bit strange
okay let's just take back
and go rgd1
and go back to h5 and now i think we can
just take and uh we probably win this
yeah but then we have to add two
connected pawns which is normally enough
he also has two two connected ones but
our pawns will be faster of course
yeah there we are okay thanks for the
game
i think i played this guy in some
russian junior championships or
something and it